you could do it because you don't need
the four corners tired but it's harder
to learn okay
you guys aren't doing it consciously in
other words you're not dismantling the
four corners to achieve you're doing it
or you wanted him more back we didn't
release your shoulders plate but you
wanted more back when you went like that
or you come wrong and you
[Music]
you need to make all those work but
you're not doing it consciously
you just have bad form okay so try try
every time you're doing it try to do it
inside and not with your shoulder blade
your elbow or your feet so if I were to
course pose and I would consciously
relax right I start my mind at my
fingertips and I consciously relax I
release as I go up my heart right why do
something imagery right I picture a blue
liquid coming up my arm and it's relaxed
and each thing do you understand
so his head is my mind he touches there
I released there he's touching there I'm
released there
I'm releasing an entity's going I want
you to think of you may not get more as
that can you understand that difference
okay he's helping me
[Music]
[Applause]
so it's not my office overlaps and I
hated it still got it do you take me
[Music]
is trying to trade my eyes not push on
what my body wants to push on do you get
it so I try to I'm trying to think about
it you you are pretty sure that that you
have to do that way you're losing it but
you can hold back because you were
already pushing on that thing okay so
I'm I'm trying to go around it and the
way to go around this don't get stuck on
don't get stuck right there I'll get
stuck cause you're gonna do this
[Music]
[Applause]
a particular structure only but it's a
better skill for learning your shoulder
blade is that you tension to reconnect
it if you did use tension
you understand it's the same thing when
you come here the problem is that she's
tension to re-establish our yeah yeah so
if I don't use tension it would be fine
you get two hours down with the real
problem yeah so I don't watch this is a
relaxation drill
[Music]